vous savez que et qu'elle est très très
heureux quand c'est que les onze ont
reprises sur les douze ça marche
d'ailleurs pas top
cent vingt mille téléspectateurs à
zagreb et bien sûr les 12 25 ans sont à
1105 c'est la première semaine de toutes
les émissions de télé en francs voilà ça
prend pas quand même ça prend pas ces
problèmes des anges à chaque nouvelle
saison il ya un problème de démarrage
mais après semaine j'attends des tons
analysant le casting est faible
honnêtement alors 120000 facile que si
les faits dans tous les cas ça nous
permet quand même à nous d'avoir
quelques pépites et on va regarder celle
là c'est une jeune femme qui donc
enfermés dehors c'est trop dehors moi je
fais pas je suis claustrophobe peux pas
m'en faire les deux heures
aussi le fait que je suis tout seul
endroit enfermé je sais pas alors qu aux
phoques dehors c'est quand même ses
origines ses deux marques un peu
faiblarde c'est les vacances deux ans et
c'est la marque low cost d orge la
marque ford énergies douces et les ans
ça marche toujours très très bien c'est
un rendez vous que les gens attendent
après c'est pour faire patienter les
gens mais c'est un très beau programme
aussi il est très bien fait mais voilà
toutes façons on y trouve ce qu'on vient
chercher non mais moi j'ai aucun je suis
pas du tout un foin avec nrj 12 va me
sers merci mais voilà après les gens
viennent y viennent chercher ce qui vous
y retrouver c'est à dire du
divertissement céda légèreté ils
viennent pas chercher de l'information
voilà le rendez-vous est la non vient ce
serait une erreur non mais vous ne coule
pas c'est 212 mille téléspectateurs pour
l'émission d'hier
assadi de comparaison les marseillais
c'est plus de 625 me mêler masisi les
masses inattentif pourquoi pas si
improbable de tf1 tout à leur ai dit
c'est de la merde et là les vacances des
anges est difficile de faire des
comédiens et tf1 avec des d'aider des
jeunes qui se plie qualité qui se monte
mais oui gilles de qui sont raillés pour
jouer une comédie qui sont un peu con
mais bien aussi je la connais très bien
lugano s'est pas mal renouvelée mais s
assumer à elle rigole ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]